hey what is going on YouTube you know
recently with all the uproar in Asian
media representation it's a little bit
hard to ignore because there seems to be
an ongoing theme and trust me I
understand the whole concept of getting
bigger white names because they sell
more tickets and if you sell more
tickets you make more money but can I
ask Hollywood and the non-asian right or
something like oh [ __ ] your characters
keep going to Asia to steal our [ __ ]
bring it back to your homeland and not
give us some [ __ ] credit for example
let's talk about the first movie in the
Dark Knight trilogy Batman Begins the
pairing stuff is not your fault
parents deserve justice then you become
something else entirely
I'll just legend
what the [ __ ] it's a random ass white
dude that somehow ended up training a
bunch of Asians some ninja [ __ ] that
they created to continue to become truly
just right invisible IV if I travel all
the way to Asia to learn some secret
Asian [ __ ] then all this research to
find out that I traveled up a frozen
[ __ ] mountain to find a white guy to
manipulate the fears and others you must
first master your own listen I'm not
trying to be offensive or anything but
I'm not here to look for Lucky Charms
you're a little Irish up here learn some
ninja [ __ ]
are you ready to begin do you know how
to kick yes does not know I'll be ready
hey can you tell me something what is it
that every time a white man is trying to
find himself he says I'll go to China
like my ancestor David Carradine that is
so hot first of all nobody goes to China
define peace we all leave China to find
that [ __ ] what in the [ __ ] have you ever
heard a Chinese immigrant say to
themselves I need to go back to China
your Paris will be right behind you
saying hey no you don't dumbass oh yeah
it's like the common reoccurring theme
in every [ __ ] movie Batman iron fist
air devil Elektra come through with
David Carradine Carol bill did you know
that there were five Karate Kid movies
and not one of them was Asian what did I
wasn't even doing karate he was a pink
kung fu from Jackie Chan telling a
little black kid to jack it off kick it
off check it off kick off and now we
have Doctor Strange oh God and by the
way we've heard all the arguments by now
people in Tibet technically don't
consider themselves Chinese and with all
the political unrest there it would be
really offensive towards the Chinese
people so the closest thing to a Tibetan
person to not offend Asian people is to
cast a bald white woman or what was that
other reason that most people say there
are no a list female Asian celebrities
right now on an international level
you're telling me that there are a
billion Asian people in this world and
not a single one can fill the role of a
wise Asian monk [ __ ] on out of here and
you can say it's because you need a big
name to fill that role either you don't
see people getting their stars made by
being in superhero movies yeah because
everybody wants to [ __ ] watch I tell
the Swinton movie if we could highlight
other minorities and these superhero
roles such as the Black Panther who
plays a African superhero King I'm
pretty sure you could somehow fill that
role for us to think about it what if
the Black Panther was
watch do you have any idea how awkward
that would be and I don't really enjoy
the whole Hollywood whitewashing
bandwagon thing but this one is a bit of
a far stretch there are too many films
where a random white person comes to
learn an Asian art that took hundreds
and thousands of years to master but
then suddenly a great white prophet of
Laguna Beach comes and [ __ ] masters
it in two months are you [ __ ] kidding
me
could you imagine for a second your
whole life training for thousands of
hours till they look like you haven't
masturbated in 300 years to have that
[ __ ] happen to you here's the thing
I found the solution I decided to create
my own movie it's about a man a Korean
who travels from the heart of Korea to
go to America to master the great art of
hamburger making might I offer you some
advice
forget everything that you think you
know your man looking at the world
through your stomach you spent your life
trying to whiten it your work has fed
thousands
but try making a decent hamburger
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
teach me me you have to look up at I
touch my girl out